Wilson and trimmer yeah I like that area
resident Boston Commons there and the
walk defend like said a lot more that's
my life - it's a 20 minute walk so many
that there are some great ways they old
y'all when you want everywhere I was
always happy but I didn't gain hanging
most of my life in the desperate
position right away
[ __ ] this [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
see
Vincent rate effectively content to be
put on the screen the me that's a good
to waste your [ __ ] time I got an
infant I was going up to 11
what's happing you bad [ __ ] the
back without the label in fact it's your
lucky night
Broly see them disease uncle Joey's here
Mumbai chocolates ahead
da 1000 sets look at least rate going
and lymphatic again unbelievable even
doing it to five years
fucking-a is so [ __ ] panicking and you
got a panic collector guess what we got
we got the horse with no name
oh [ __ ] when you have the horse with no
name there's always going to be a [ __ ]
wrong understanding snails end up on
Miami devotion unto others experiences -
really Oh
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
like a school over there I can yell to
hear Mexican ID if you have 18 hang up
now it's going to be a good night yeah I
mean I'll be fired up whatever you want
you always line up whoever you want me I
can email them to know maybe fellows
we're off tonight
okay let these [ __ ] know what
the direction of saying who the [ __ ] is
running things inside [ __ ] I
didn't get my steps into the jumper okay
good jumping jacks and talking about who
I was talking about jumping jacks Reaper
and nothing but heart and balls you
understand me
that's what I'm talking about looking
grow these seeds and stuff and [ __ ]
work dr. Maurice I have to comment with
a marine mentality look look but no then
they don't lend you fat [ __ ]
[Music]
ah it's uncle Joey time you bad
[ __ ] we're back you guys like
what the [ __ ] are you where you been
we've been here all along it's you
that's been missing welcome June [ __ ]
seventh the day the devil was buried at
sea the only difference is you're on
board you understand me with a
tremendous week tonight we're at the
horse with no name and we got a horse
with no label you understand me but it's
got the label that means we take no
responsibility you're on your own in the
[ __ ] valium
[Music]
oh not my smoking reefer would you
people a beautiful night
like I said Brody Stephens is here he's
doing [ __ ] jumping jacks right now
still from the reefer this reefer gives
you a weird a sudden urge to do jumping
jacks let me do the jumping jack anyway
we're going to get this party started
early cuz leaves look at that Megan I'm
saying start number one as usual we
don't even [ __ ] around
we don't even say hello we don't say
goodbye we don't say I miss you
we don't say not to understand me
he is
made by blue aprons
oh [ __ ] there you go Lee are you ready
for the final countdown Lebanese if I
would begin to do everything to you
that's it just one book just one for my
main some company don't thinking my
watching me sleep
beautiful if you on the 18 now listen
hang up now it's this type of party
tonight I'm talking button here at the
church we take you into a complete
different realm and you know what I
[ __ ] love it actually I could do this
every night he's the one that told me no
please
again why are we doing this because this
is what we do but if this is Boston
already
he hasn't even tasted the chocolate he
hasn't even done the bongo effect yet
he's already popular there but it's
alright we're going to have a good time
to let you know why because the man with
the plan is here be Stevens be Stevens
you understand me get out in the field
put the mule and the stable in the Sammy
papa
she's our cooking put the meat on the
table
always remember when you're messing
around with THC you want to have Yagami
that I like those be another oh yeah
these are strong we're going into the
[ __ ] Mirko Cro Cop kick to the head
tonight you understand me can you
imagine what it's like to get kicked in
the head my mental problem
no we'll come over to the Voodoo Lounge
oh it's [ __ ] me this bond is believed
because you say they're going when is my
shift gonna come in what is my ship
gonna come in there's another tremendous
out one of my top [ __ ] head out it
was written with heroin up in Boston one
of those catacombs up there
this is Aerosmith's like third or fourth
out it's a [ __ ] Mack the beach and
the family just like you are you reading
Lee find out let's do this then aunt
aunt aunt aunt aunt is a beautiful bond
tonight so mule is kicking the
temperatures right this is smooth for
that hold on hold on the mule and suck
suck suck suck
there you go hit that hit that me hey
girl
that's the one the mules in batches
right there see a week ago he couldn't
handle if you think it's more training
assistant he couldn't do these look at
me I'll bring up some this and I'll show
that later on about we're going to kill
that right think of it
why don't know what to do the student
and I talking through some super section
if you're some body bullying for your
lungs it's going to do some super bong
is here is how you get your lungs and
shape in tip-top shape or if you wants
to blow clouds but they want to get a
paper face
they not here there you go super to
raise them comforting [ __ ] nails in
the family looking fizzling [ __ ] up
my lady's a training training pays off
if you have a problem with bottom start
super setting them and all work out for
you in the family that means don't put
the bomb down the eyes [ __ ] turn
purple wet die blues and
[Music]
just like that and don't forget tomorrow
night me and Leah driving down the bread
90 miles an hour it's like so we'll
leave it here at 7:30 in the family
it usually takes you two hours to get
the bread we'll make it a half hour
tomorrow night that's all blowing money
stars and put that foot on the gas
[ __ ]
and by the way we got no insurance we're
going for broke without like the Mexican
Sukkot no insurance I hate you I move
doctor me yeah my commitment and I come
back with a new name please bad bad
[ __ ] youth I love that you come
or a family on periscope smoking token
eating stars to get who said chocolately
mommy you got one more to you something
up another fun it is cannot walk around
here who runs a bonnet you know nobody
knows how they going on yeah go find a
new penguin and I'm going to give you a
big bump in relief gonna give you a baby
[ __ ]
believe you recent rain we've had
[ __ ] understand
we went
[Music]
but night when I'm [ __ ] dead please
47 he's gonna sit lap about his mind
little what the [ __ ] I was living like a
doctor with my own hotel smoking reefer
for one I do now I'm living like Henry
Hill I gotta sleep with the windows
[ __ ] two shades closed only focuses
oh [ __ ] look how beautiful as matters
yes one he is you got at rody Stevens
feeling Brody that's why I am it's the
real deal Joey gets it he saw me in
Seattle finding my voice
he sent me to New York to own it and I
came back in 2000 and look at me now
BAM
[Music]
shotgun me in the mouth with it there
you go look at that [ __ ] Sun mo
Blakely
yeah a gentleman it wasn't work that's
right [ __ ] it's a Wednesday
night and you're sitting there going
what's going on with my life
look get it together grab grandma's
sleeping pill I don't give a [ __ ] what
you got to do Michael Jackson was doing
[ __ ] fetanyl whatever the [ __ ] you
cat doesn't have some something diabetes
throws us up
take those this is I don't think who's
ready for chocolate repast oh [ __ ]
sure it will mentally he [ __ ] up
tonight imitating little bit but
[Music]
you thought you thought you were gonna
have a ho-hum night uncle Joey showed up
the animals and with two [ __ ]
goofballs effect where this is the murky
water
and our liquid after two don't usually
kill the paranoia liquid acid kills a
paranoid
[Music]
[Music]
what happens here the booboo Mouse
[Music]
nobody gets into the boo-boo lounge
unless you got resumes references and
you always gotta show up on an envelope
you know that right off the bat you'll
say I can't show something's outfit with
a bottle of wine I want wine like I want
Jesus the puppets bit my face something
he said get below food
and that's it that's that you know what
[Music]
doesn't stack in the case is an
earthquake in that case I'm gonna hit
the myth while you here you hit the side
and [ __ ] you know what
[Music]
because the red one we got the blue ones
we got the [ __ ] with you
we got the earthquake week
we got a recycled piece of gum we're
coming at you from all directions
[Music]
oh Jesus claim he still has a half a bar
left and he's shakin and shiverin and
we're going to [ __ ] chase it with
what's gone we'll call it which hates
mr. Monty to start with a piece of
chocolate it's like a raspberry
chocolate I did it the NI raspberry
children could be insane people you know
my intention for [ __ ] life my
intentions are good but Lisa I always
want to [ __ ] around and you know you
don't train on the weekends you don't
eat the chocolate toy all right that's
right I told you see this [ __ ] together
call HR that's not against protocol as
it gets [ __ ] heat that chocolate con
ellos a Philly roll and that's some
[ __ ] Chilean seabass
coming at you direct from the Hudson
River
you know what those spots not like oh
[ __ ]
here we go leave the chopper to get the
podcast on at 22 after seven years
we are planning to do Authority
direction to do you sitting around I
have no [ __ ] idea
I'm just trying to put the pieces
together just like the [ __ ] another guy
taxes there's everybody's got their
[ __ ] hand down are you supposed to
make a [ __ ]
pow you think I'm [ __ ] [ __ ] what you
cut stuff is what's going on wait it's
alright it's gonna be alright
you're gonna live when I finish up that
bag of stars tonight
I'm gonna take it to the next level that
they listen some people do [ __ ] they
have a party act this way we act like
this on a Wednesday follow me just got
that man we just got this back we're
gonna kill this on one [ __ ] night why
because what else we're not doing what
we have a museum with stars it
when I'm on a constellation I don't give
a [ __ ] we got ooh what we got about six
cars where's the rest of the trunk come
on let's go yellow piece of children
that we have some xanaxs we have some
[ __ ] cancer pills we got some tumor
halls just in case you got cancer will
[ __ ] around
we're here to help you out like I told
you don't forget tomorrow that we're
going deep into bread we're bringing one
of these big bag of red stars it's going
to be a tremendous show you got cake
quigley up front and beam Del Ray sing
an ac/dc in the middle of the stash it's
a tremendous show you need the [ __ ]
magician and a [ __ ] week all those
people had done a mine that says also on
one second don't run away I got part
number two Aerosmith Rock's 1975 before
the Bicentennial there's no 9vg
chocolate don't worry about them can't
we just make each each other tradition
you still got a bond it
you still got saw I know that's
different around me
like somebody said you are you going
buddy one of the manga T okay you're
good there you go are you thinking for
someplace here we go
I just got to talk to you please don't
get your hand this is the first now no
this is the third out 1975 people on the
side there missed everything after 1860
the older this is as good as it gets
Rockne Perelman they were dirty they
weren't really making money don't wither
no Facebook just playing and dirty fan
very sleep all around the way we oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] here we go leave
at that time we safely leave very
important especially when you messing
around with barbiturates and THC
products every family let's pretend you
like need a few annexes inside the time
you guys drink wanting us well out of
the back it's not a consistent and every
time you go through two loads and up a
bullet Cosby get me you know why because
you didn't watch that [ __ ] out of your
[ __ ] system that's what you murdered
tonight we don't a joke this is a lot my
husband he I always give you some
strength of the heart the thing like
drugs anklets of [ __ ] do with a mask
on and a foreign voice
very profound and even except they're
like John the cement
you
[Music]
[Applause]
namely tells it to them because it doll
cachito sick as a zombie kokanee over
you ready go take that beep this is a
[ __ ] strategy
[Music]
they also made it nice for small and
take the floor you stick with it stick
with it don't go away just inhale
breathe out of your nose and then get
ready a blast right here there you go
there you go that's the one that's the
one that's the one that killed Abdullah
that's the one right there that's the
one sometimes mule sucks at me there you
go that's the one that's the one like
that how are you holy [ __ ] [ __ ] the hot
dog eating contest we're doing a Banga
contest next year Coney Island guess
who's number one coach uncle [ __ ]
Joey
oh I'm making [ __ ] man out of [ __ ]
young boys here with the bomb in seven
weeks you too can smell pockets like
this that's right you two you ought to
get up [ __ ] half a [ __ ] paper pen that
make-believe your international like a
[ __ ] book the Lord no for only $4.99
you do is smoke reefer like a snappy
your friends will sit there you'll be
more interesting a party people will say
what happened to my weed kind of obvious
somebody [ __ ] smoked it it was the
guy with the big long skinny standard
take it back right here gonna take it
this is some real [ __ ] heroin
[ __ ] right here this is a joke Perry
this is one of my all-time favorite Joe
Perry solos coming at you it's called
nobody's falling
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
here we go
I hope you enjoyed the preacher tonight
what I'm [ __ ] around understand if
you need to go to a rehab take care of
it but if you're what uncle Joey you'll
be fine
just fine people always panic if you're
smoking dope and you're going to work
you go to school you alright don't worry
about nothing
it gives the [ __ ] the only people have a
problem of the people who don't have a
problem make that the people don't have
a [ __ ] problem to step forward and
blow a [ __ ] stone at the glass out
well anyway here's what's going to
happen you're going to go to youtube.com
that's black the black Joey did I want
to come into your living room and about
10 minutes guy here's your chance go
make some [ __ ] lift in soup with the
sour cream from onion [ __ ] chips sit
down and watch awful jumpy that's you've
lifted soup with [ __ ] sour cream
you take the [ __ ] chicken soup mix oh
yeah and it becomes an onion dip can you
[ __ ] a lot of people don't do that no
more that's old-school or you take what
do you put South in cream cheese yes I
know you take salsa with cream cheese
take a bunch of houses throw the cream
cheese with the Schism and it's ugly
this guy want to be a white Mexican and
then he goes there you go
[Music]
anyway you know I love your
[ __ ] youtube.com slash b-flat
Joey did take a look at this
yes you got I stretched it out it's good
good I didn't get my apple cider vinegar
in because I left my orange juice out
overnight but that's okay I got a
chocolate store and already have a good
time you've been listening to see Brody
Stephens much I'm here at the church
yeah I used to go to church in 82 the
year Eric I missed the Sun time mr. Ram
gates on Sundays and you're Eric
Dickerson rushed for 2,000 yards I
missed every game because I was a Jewish
guy in church yeah Santino California
little [ __ ] do you think you're dealing
with you think I'm going to show up with
some knock knock how you doing
[ __ ] huh some
johnny-come-lately some lay down Sally
look at [ __ ] but it is never
never youtube.com slash c / Joey Diaz if
not I feel you [ __ ] tomorrow night
8 o'clock brain props cake wiggly fiend
Delray line up a deck down inbred stay
black
[Music]